[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We have a
distinguished speaker
among us, Lukman Ramsey.
He is a solution architect
for AI and ML in Google Cloud.
He joined Google
Cloud after acting
as a CTO for a series
of New York startups
in education technology,
AI, and speech recognition.
His PhD work has been
in computer science
at UC San Diego, doing computer
vision research and GPL
in machine learning
systems group.
As an undergrad at MIT in
cognitive science and computer
science, he worked on a
multi-layer neural network
before it was called
deep learning.
His academic
interests have always
centered on the intersection of
cognitive science and computer
science.
So as you can see, [INAUDIBLE],,
we are honored to have you,
Lukman.
Take it away.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: --everybody
for coming tonight.
It is an honor to be here
at this meetup event.
Previous speakers have all
been very distinguished people
in this world of machine
learning and Google.
And so I'm very honored
to be counted among them.
So tonight's topic is optimizing
TensorFlow models for serving.
We're going to discuss the
technical infrastructure
for serving, how to serve
TensorFlow models on Google
Cloud in particular,
and how even more so
to make that process efficient
and make those models
go fast so that we can reduce
the cost of our ML applications
and increase the utilization
of the resources that
are required.
This work is based on a
blog post that was published
on Medium a month ago.
So almost all the
information that I'm
going to talk about tonight
is also on this blog post,
if you want to go
and read about it.
There's also code
available for everything
that I'm going to be talking
about in the Google Cloud
Platform organization,
under this project
called TF estimator
tutorials, which, by the way,
has a bunch of other really
cool, interesting stuff in it.
This code is living in
a sub folder of just
one of the sections there.
But I would encourage you
to check the repository out.
And it was also done
in collaboration
with Khaled Salama, who is also
a solutions architect in Google
Cloud, focused on
machine learning,
and so I wanted to make
sure to call him out.
Here's our agenda.
We're going to talk about
goals and metrics for serving.
What we are trying to achieve
here is to optimize serving,
and so we need some
metrics in order
to quantify that optimization.
We're going to talk a
little bit about model
formats in TensorFlow.
There are a lot of model
In its short life, it's
managed to accumulate several.
And this area of serving
TensorFlow models
involves having some
deeper knowledge
about what those model
formats are, how, ultimately,
to load them using code
and operate on them,
and so on, and transform them.
We'll talk about
optimization tools that
are useful for this purpose.
There are several tools
present in the TensorFlow code
base that can be used to
optimize TensorFlow models.
There are also
facilities or tools
to optimize TensorFlow that
are built into the TensorFlow
runtime as well.
Matter of fact, much of what
we will talk about today
should be, in an ideal
world, done by the TensorFlow
runtime automatically without
you having to think about it.
But as we will see, that's
not always the case.
So it is very
useful to understand
the kinds of optimizations
that are at play here
and how to do them yourself.
There are contexts in which
you need to be able to do that.
We will talk about the
various technical options
for serving TensorFlow models.
And then finally, I'll
conclude with an example
of a convolutional neural net
for the MNIST data set that
demonstrates all of this stuff.
Again, we should
have time for Q&A.
So I will be happy to take
questions during the talk
if you have them, but I
also will leave some time
at the end for Q&A.
All right.
Let's dive right in.
So here is how to
frame the problem.
Given a TensorFlow
trained model,
we would like to optimize
the speed of prediction.
We mean, for a single
example that you
gave to this model for
prediction, optimize
the time that it takes to
perform that prediction.
And in general, in
a broader sense,
we would like to
optimize the throughput.
So the number of
examples are inputs per
second that the system
that's performing the serving
can process.
Also interested, in some cases,
in decreasing model size.
Model size has an impact
in lots of things.
In many contexts, you care
about the size of your model.
For example, if you're
deploying models to the edge
or to mobile devices, you
would like those models
to be as small as possible so
that they download as fast as
possible, use as little
bandwidth as possible,
that they use a smallest
memory footprint on the device.
There are also cases where there
are actual hard limitations
that you run up against
with respect to model size.
So for example, if you're
using hardware acceleration
to serve your models,
in many cases,
this is limited by
the amount of memory
on the GPU, the
acceleration device.
And in Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
which is one of
the methods that we
will talk about later for
serving models, for example,
there is a quota limit
imposed on the model size.
I think, by default, it's
something like 512 megabytes
for model size.
Now, that's not a hard limit.
You can make a request
and get that increased.
But nonetheless, it's something
that you may run into.
Your model may end up being
too big to accommodate
whatever serving method that
you're trying to achieve.
So it's important to understand
what factors influence
the size of your
model, and if there's
anything to do about it,
what you can do about it.
This just replicates what I
just said about model size.
So as you can see, size does
matter with respect to models.
So we should be aware of
what factors influence
the size of our models,
and then ultimately,
what we can do about it.
And like I said, prediction
speed, not just important
when we're talking about
serving a single example.
Because in the end, that's
a measure, basically,
of the complexity of
the model, and the time
that it takes to
serve a single example
will be related to the
throughput in the end--
it's a critical factor
in the throughput.
And in turn, that throughput
is related to the amount
of resources that you're
going to use in order
to serve your
models, which is then
related to the amount of
cost that you're going
to expend to serve models.
And relatively small differences
in that speed or throughput
can have a big impact in
the ROI of your machine
learning application.
So if you can decrease
the amount of resources
necessary to serve your
models by something
not insignificant,
say, 5% or 10%,
then this should correspondingly
decrease the amount of costs
that it requires to support your
machine learning application,
which can have a big impact in
the ROI of that application.
There's also many cases
where prediction speed
is essential to the
application itself,
in cases where we want
to get the result back
as fast as possible because it
makes a difference in the user
experience.
So we care about prediction
speed, in general,
and we want to make it
as fast as possible.
Prediction throughput,
like I said,
is related to prediction
speed, but includes
other factors, such as
batching, horizontal scaling,
meaning how many
parallel resources are
you devoting to serving and
how many examples can you
process in parallel.
Obviously, network
performance is
going to have an
impact on throughput.
Things that aren't
necessarily related
to TensorFlow or to
machine running at all.
Compute performance,
of course, including
whether you're using
hardware acceleration or not.
And a bunch of
other stuff that's
beyond our current scope.
So today, we're really
going to just focus
on how to optimize a trained
TensorFlow model, as I said,
to predict as fast as possible.
And then, of course,
the other stuff matters,
but that's beyond
our current scope.
So let's talk a little bit
more about the TensorFlow model
formats and how they are
implicated in all this.
So there are more than
what you see here.
Here, I'm showing two
formats, the graph def
and the saved model.
You probably are familiar
with the saved model
if you've trained TensorFlow
models, because this is now
the most common model format
that, for example, when
you train a model
using an estimator
and you export that model,
it's going to be exported
as a saved model.
The saved model actually
includes a graph def
plus a set of saved weights,
basically, as files in a folder
structure.
So a saved model is
not a single file,
it's a folder that
contains the definition
of your graph in this
graph def format,
and in addition,
some weights that
are in a separate set of
files that are merged together
with that graph when you
are serving the model.
The graph def is a either
text or binary file
format that uses the
protobuf file format
or the protobuf data structure
format, which you probably
are familiar with.
It's very ubiquitous across
everything that Google does.
And so it could be, again,
either in text or in binary.
But it basically represents
all of the node structure
of your graph.
So any TensorFlow model can
be expressed as a graph,
and the graph def
just really encodes
the structure of that graph.
So again, the saved model
consists of a graph def
plus a set of weights.
Actually, more accurate to say
that the saved model includes
what's called a meta graph.
So this is a graph def that
includes some extra information
about what we call the serving
signature of the model, which
is the inputs and
outputs of the model.
So a saved model is a
meta graph plus a bunch
of weights stored in separate
files or folder structure.
This is all very
important to know
when we're trying to
operate on these models
and try to optimize
them, because we
have to understand what the
underlying data structures are.
But we'll talk about several
basic optimization techniques,
including freezing
the graph, pruning
the graph, something
called constant folding,
an operation called folding
batch norms, and quantization.
And there are actually many
other kinds of optimizations
that can be done.
Including a few of them here.
We're not going to go into
gory detail about any of these,
but these are good
ones to know about
for optimization techniques.
And as I mentioned,
actually, there
are components of the
TensorFlow runtime, which
we will talk about that perform
many of these optimizations
as well.
Tools that we will use
are really two main ones.
There's something
called a graph transform
tool, which has been
in the TensorFlow code
base for some time, the
world of TensorFlow for eons,
since 2016.
And that in the blog post,
and then the examples
that I'm going to cover is the
main tool that we will use.
However, there is another
tool called grappler
that is present in the
TensorFlow runtime that
is performing a lot of
these optimizations,
again, for-- it should be, in
a theoretical sense, for you
automatically, such that you
don't have to think about it.
The reality is a little
bit different than that.
We'll talk more about
why that is the case.
The graph transform tool, by
the way, is a command line tool,
but it also has a
Python interface.
Grappler is basically a
component of the TensorFlow
runtime that recently
also got a Python
API associated with it as well.
So you can call
both of these things
through Python code, which
is what we will do here.
But in the case of the GTT,
the graph transform tool,
there's also just a command line
version of that you can use.
So in summary, the
optimization process is this.
We're going to take a
saved model, which, again,
is by far the most common
format that you probably
are dealing with when you've
got a trained TensorFlow
model that's been exported.
We're going to convert
that into a graph def.
And that process is
called freezing the model.
Basically, merging the weights
that are saved out externally
with the graph, such
that it now is all
contained in a single file.
Why would we need to do that
before we start optimizing?
The answer is that if you
keep the weights separate
from the graph and you start
operating on the graph,
pruning it and changing
it and optimizing it,
then that structure
that existed before
and the weights is no longer
going to map back to the graph,
and you won't be able to
upload those weights back in.
You might be removing
nodes, you might
be collapsing nodes together.
And so, effectively,
if you don't do this,
you will have a broken model.
So really, this model freezing
step is the first step in any
optimization process, so
that when you're dealing with
a graph that contains all of the
weights merged into the graph
as opposed to stored separately,
so that then when we operate
on that graph, again, pruning
nodes and merging nodes
together and changing the
structure of the graph,
that we don't-- a structure
now that no longer--
where the weights and the graph
don't have the same structure.
Once we've done that, once
we've frozen the model,
then we can optimize
the model by basically
operating on that graph, again,
doing all kinds of operations
that we'll talk about to the
graph that involve shrinking
the graph size and making the
graph more efficient, such
that it contains
fewer operations--
optimizing it.
And then once we've
done that, we're
going to want to convert
that back to a saved model,
because in the end,
the saved model
is the most useful model format.
So if you're going to
be loading this model
into a serving process, like
TensorFlow Serving or a cloud
machine running engine, it's
going to want a saved model.
Not the case that
when you do that,
you somehow re-export those
weights out to separate files.
So a saved model can
consist of a graph
file that has all of the
weights merged into it,
and then just an empty
set of directories
that contain nothing, and
TensorFlow is fine with that.
But we still need to add
this meta graph information
that I mentioned
back to the graph def
to convert it from a graph
def into a saved model graph.
But we don't need to be
re-export the weights,
so the weights will still
be merged into this--
it'll still be a
single file, basically,
just a saved model
folder structure
that has just this one file in
it that represents the model.
So let's talk a little
bit more in detail
about freezing the model.
Again, this says this
basically consists
of merging the weights
into the graph,
giving you a single file.
I mentioned that already.
I covered that pretty well.
So pruning is another
optimization process
that we'll talk about
that essentially consists
of a set of operations that
reduce the size of the graph,
either removing extra nodes
that aren't necessary--
we call, for example,
identity nodes, meaning,
nodes that act like the
multiplication of one,
or basically, they're like no-op
nodes that don't do anything
to the graph or don't affect
the computation that's
being performed by the graph.
Other things that--
operations that you
might do in TensorFlow,
like shuffling on a tensor
of size 1 or reduction of
dimensions, empty dimensions,
and things that happen in the
course of model development
or in the course of operating
on your TensorFlow model
that the optimization
process can eliminate,
which then results in a
smaller, more efficient graph.
In addition, a lot of
the times when you're
developing a graph in TensorFlow
through some of the APIs,
there will be multiple output
nodes created, meaning--
and an output node
is basically a node
of the graph that
produces the answer.
And so it's not always
the case that you
have one set of outputs for
a TensorFlow graph, sometimes
you have multiple outputs.
But it's almost always the
case that when you're actually
using the graph, you only
care about one of the outputs.
And so when you actually use the
graph in a production context,
then you want to make sure
that none of those other output
nodes are present in the
graph, because that's
just extra computation
that the graph is
doing that is not necessary.
So we want to make sure that
we remove extra outputs.
It's not always the
case that you'll
have these extra outputs,
but there are some APIs
that when you use them
produce multiple outputs.
It's possible that when you
define your graph, however
you're doing that, using
the high level API,
that you would get
multiple output nodes.
And so this is one of the
things that we had to prune.
So constant folding is basically
merging constant operations
that might be chained together
and just pre-computing them.
Using batch norms is
actually similar to this.
So I don't know-- who's familiar
with batch normalization?
A few of you.
If you're not familiar
with batch normalization,
I would say you should be.
It's becoming-- I would call
it a standard technique that
may have been a research
technique a couple of years
ago, but by now, anybody who's
doing serious deep learning
should be using batch
norm inside their models.
In fact, as of, I
think, TensorFlow 1.10,
they included batch
normalization in the canned
estimators of TensorFlow.
So it's actually
all built into the--
if you're going to specify a
deep neural net using the DNN
estimator classes, you have the
option to turn batch norm on.
So again, it's almost
always the case
that you actually
want to do batch norm.
There's not really time to
talk about that in detail,
what batch norm is.
But trust me, if
you're not using it
and you have a
deep neural network
or a convolutional neural
net, you should be.
Effectively, what it does is
normalizes the activations
of each layer as the layers--
as those activation values
propagate up through the model
by looking at the statistics
of the data, basically.
Starting with the input
data, namely, the batches
of data that you're
feeding into the model,
but even as you go up
through the layers, there's
a computation that's
being done so that--
by normalizing, meaning
subtracting away the mean
and centering those values.
This turns out to make learning
much easier and faster.
But in the end, you're computing
some statistics on those inputs
and on the values of
those activations,
and those statistics are
pre-computed during training,
they're not computed
during predictions.
So the statistics are
computed as a mean
and a standard deviation
during the training process,
and then they're embedded
as constant values
inside the network.
And you can just merge those
constant multiplications
that are happening there
into the graph itself.
So that's a lot of explanation
about what using batch norm
is, but it does give
us the opportunity
to talk about batch
normalization and what it is
and why you should
know about it.
Yeah?
I guess the answer
to the question
is yes, that we are explicitly
doing operations to a model
to prepare it for serving.
And if you wanted to, say, do
further training on that model,
say, incremental training
or add more training,
that, yeah, you would
not want to have
this fused optimized model.
Instead, you would want
to start with a model that
still had the batch
normalization structure in it.
So yeah.
We're really talking
about a process
that we apply to models after
they're trained to prepare them
for serving.
Yeah, that's right.
In other words, we're
computing statistics
based upon an exponentially
weighted average
of the previous values.
And again, we don't need
to go into gory detail
about what batch norm
is or how it works.
But you should at least--
the concept or the name
should be familiar to you.
I advise you, if you don't
know what it is, learn about it
and learn how you--
what you should know or
what you should make sure
is that it's on
inside your model.
Hopefully, the
frameworks-- certainly
Keras will do this for you, as
well as some of these canned
estimators.
But for those of us that
are building custom models,
we have to explicitly include
batch norm inside our model
definition.
Quantization is quite a
big topic in and of itself,
but essentially refers to taking
the weights inside a model
and reducing their precision.
So going from a 32-bit weight,
in some cases, a 64-bit weight,
and reducing down to a
16-bit or an 8-bit weight.
This does reduce the accuracy
of the model in many cases,
but not by much.
And you can get a really big
boost in speed and performance
by quantizing, and you get
a much, much reduced model
size as well.
Because most of the size of a
model is due to its weights.
And so if you can reduce
the amount of data
that it takes to store those
weights by a factor of four,
you get a much,
much smaller model.
Quantization is
really implicated
in a lot of what we do with
respect to model optimization
these days.
Again, for the time, you
don't have to really know
about the details of this.
It's done for you.
But there are cases
where you really
have to understand quantization
and how to apply it.
And if you do that,
you can get really big
boosts in performance,
certainly in speed,
but also in model size.
Now, at a cost, by the way,
of some amount of accuracy.
So if you're going to apply
quantization to your model--
actually, really, this
applies to all of the things
that we talked about here--
you should test before and
after to make sure that nothing
that you did changes
your accuracy
or the precision
of your results,
at least not in a way that makes
your use case no longer valid.
Again, this is what
the transformation
looks like when you're doing
quantization inside a graph.
You're taking something that is
a simple sequence of floating
point operations--
so here, we have an input
where a relu activation
function is being applied
to it that produces
an output, and instead--
because, again, you're
reducing the precision,
and so you need to know what
the range is of that weight
so that you can map it back.
So you have to
pre-compute, which
the system will do for you or
the optimization tools will do
for you, the min and the max.
Then you reduce the precision,
you perform the calculation,
and then you map it back to the
original floating point value.
And folks heard about
TensorFlow Lite.
So this is a system
introduced last year,
basically, to optimize the
deployment of TensorFlow models
on mobile devices.
One of the key techniques
that TensorFlow Lite is doing
to make models work well
and fast on mobile devices
is quantizing down to 8 bits.
So in this case,
TensorFlow Lite actually
does all this
quantization for you.
You don't have to
worry about it.
But that is the secret sauce
under a lot of what TensorFlow
Lite is doing, is basically
quantizing your model
down to 8-bit.
I talked a fair bit about all
the various optimizations.
Let's look in more
detail at an example.
We're just going to talk about
a MNIST convolutional neural
net, which is a standard neural
net that you might deal with.
And this is the full
optimization process
that we will apply.
First, we will run predictions
so that we know the model
output before we applied
all over optimizations
and we know how fast it ran.
So we have to do that
before so that we
have some kind of
benchmark or baseline
so that we know what effect
our optimizations had.
We also want to run
predictions so that we
can verify, as I said, which
we should always do at the end,
that we didn't break
our model or do anything
that would reduce the
precision of our model
or broke the output.
It's quite easy, frankly,
to break your model
by doing this stuff to it.
And so you want to
make sure that you
can verify that the model
at the end of the process
still performs well, or at
least in an accurate way.
And then you also
want to be able
quantify the effect
of the optimizations.
So you need to have a baseline
benchmark at the beginning.
Then you freeze the graph,
you run the optimizations.
Again, we're going to show this
using the graph transform tool,
but there's also this, actually,
more advanced and more recent
tool called grappler
that you can also use.
We'll convert that model
back to a saved model format,
and then we rerun
the predictions
to verify that we
didn't break it,
that it's still as accurate
as we need it to be.
And we also benchmark
at that point
to quantify the effect
of our optimizations.
Let me just say a few words
about benchmarking methodology.
There could be a whole
separate talk on that,
but it's really
important, I think,
to be careful about
how we benchmark.
Because if we're
not careful, then we
may draw some
incorrect conclusions
about what we just did.
We may decide that,
oh, these optimizations
didn't work at all because it
makes the prediction longer.
And so it's important to have
some consistent benchmarking
methodology and to pay
attention to what we do here.
And again, like I said, I won't
go into gory detail about this,
but I just want to say that
the three desirable attributes
of a benchmark are that
it's repeatable, meaning,
that you get the
same answer when
you run it multiple times--
oftentimes, because
computers are a little bit
indeterministic,
frankly, in varying ways,
you often won't get necessarily
the same exact results.
So when we say repeatable,
we're not necessarily
saying you get the
exact same result,
but it needs to be within
a small range, needs
to have low variance.
We want to run the benchmarks
in a controlled environment,
meaning, you have to
have a lot of control
about all of the different
components that we're testing.
If there's some part
of that component
that we don't control, say,
for example, the network--
if you're running a
benchmark from your laptop
across the cloud to something
that's running in the cloud,
you've got a big chunk
of stuff that you
have no control over
there between you
and what you're running.
And we also want to make
sure the benchmark has
a limited focus,
meaning, it's only
testing the things that
we're interested in
and not trying to test
lots of different things.
Because, again, that reduces the
amount of control that we have.
By definition, testing more
things makes it more likely
that there's some
part of that system.
So again, that's all I
want to say about that.
But it influences
the choice of how
we might decide to
benchmark our model
optimizations because
there are multiple ways
that we could do that.
So one of them would be
just to use pure Python.
It's a very easy thing
to do now, particularly
with this contra
predictor module that
was added to TensorFlow
that allows you to perform
predictions in Python.
Now, of course, this
is TensorFlow 1.0
that has the contrib
package, which is going away.
AUDIENCE: It's migrated--
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Migrating.
It's not going away, right.
Yeah, that's the
wrong way to say it.
It's migrating to somewhere else
where it will be still useful--
still be able to be used.
Anyway, that's a
potential method.
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine predict service--
very useful, important
service, which I'll
talk a little bit
more about later.
Very, very useful for
production prediction.
You can train your models on
Cloud Machine Learning Engine,
and then you can very
easily take that same model
and set up a predict
service for it on the cloud.
And then another option
would be TF serving, which
is another serving option.
Again, I will actually
talk a little bit more
about all the various
serving options later using
just a REST call.
So basically,
running an instance
a TF serving in a
container locally.
Of these three, can anybody
say which is the best?
So the answer is
TF serving locally.
The Python method
suffers from the fact
that Python itself is not a
very controlled environment
because it's an interpreter
that is doing a lot of things
under the hood that you
have no control over,
like garbage collection.
And it tends to just be very
non-deterministic from run
to run.
If you try running
your code using Python,
even if you do make
it more statistically
valid by doing bigger
batches or more predictions,
you will find that the
results are quite variable.
You could overcome this.
You could run the benchmark 10
times and average the results.
But you'd rather
not have to do that.
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine, as we said,
the challenge is to see you
running something in the cloud,
and you're trying to
test that locally,
or even if you're having an
instance on the cloud that's
making calls out to
Machine Learning Engine
to do that predict,
there's a lot of stuff
there that you just
have no control over.
And Machine Learning Engine
predict is a managed service,
so that means it's handling
a lot of the scaling
issues for you.
So in the middle of
your benchmark run,
it might see that
your load is spiking
and try to allocate some
more instances for you
to do this prediction,
which would then
throw your benchmark results
off completely and not
be very repeatable.
So not a great choice.
Running TF serving locally
in a docker container
is actually quite controlled.
And it should be quite
consistent from run to run,
because, again, you're
running it on your laptop,
you've got a lot of
other processes running
at the same time, and that
could influence the result.
But nonetheless, of
those three options,
it's, I would claim, the best.
And so that's the one that
we used in the blog post.
Again, in the code
that's out on GitHub,
you will see all three
options as examples,
so you could test
each of them out.
And it's also just
useful to have
sample code that uses the contra
predictor to do predictions.
You may not have even
known that that existed,
the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
Also useful to have
an example of that.
And then finally, the
deploying and using TF
serving in a local container
as well is also useful.
I'm going to make a little
diversion here quickly
to talk about the
various options
for serving TensorFlow in
a production environment.
We've talked about Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
the predict service thereof.
It's a managed service.
A lot of great features
for doing prediction.
A very easy transition
from training to predict.
Basically, in your training
process, at the end of it,
you export the saved
model, and then it's
very easy to launch
a predict service
from that same saved model.
You can do online predictions
and batch predictions.
It contains facilities
to do model versioning.
It does support other
frameworks than TensorFlow now.
So Scikit-Learn and XGBoost.
And I was asked by the product
manager or the tech lead
here to mention that
very soon, you'll
be able to deploy predict
on any machine type that's
available in GCE.
So you'll have even more control
over the kinds of machines
that you're running on,
and also to harness GPUs.
So really good
option for deploying
your models and the
predictions, again,
if you're interested in a
managed service, meaning,
you don't need to have
very strong control
over the underlying
architecture.
Very good for deploying your
models to production, not so
great as a benchmarking
tool necessarily.
TF serving we talked about.
Based on a open source
component from the TFX platform,
which is Google's internal
platform for machine learning
pipelines, which we are now open
sourcing the components of one
after the other.
I believe the serving component
was the first component that
was open sourced.
One of the nice things
about TF serving
is that it has the facility to
update the models dynamically,
meaning, it can be up and
running, serving your examples,
and then you swap in a
new model under the hood
and TF serving
will automatically
pick that up and just seamlessly
transition from the old model
to the new one.
There's a large community
inside Google and outside Google
that's using TF serving.
I will say, if
you're using GPUs,
it is challenging to harness
multiple GPUs using TF serving.
It can be done, but you have to
encode the device assignments
in the graph.
And so that's one, I would
say, drawback of TF serving.
If you really have stringent
throughput requirements
for your serving
application and you really
need to have running
on machines that
have four or eight GPUs
attached with them,
then it's a challenging
thing to do with TF serving.
The architecture for a
serving system and production
looks like this, where
you typically would deploy
TF serving inside a Kubernetes
cluster, where each node has
its own instance of TF serving.
And then you have some kind
of load balancer in front
that is distributing
those serving requests
across the nodes.
There's an option from
our partner NVIDIA called
NVIDIA Inference Server,
which includes the capability
to harness something
called TensorRT, which I'll
talk about a little more,
that basically harnesses
some of the capabilities
of the newer NVIDIA GPUs.
They have something called a
tensor core unit inside them.
Actually, this tensor core unit
that is used under TensorRT
is basically harnessing
quantization.
So under the hood, it's
converting your weights
into 16-bit and it's got
hardware acceleration.
It's really, really fast for
processing with these weights.
This feature is present in
the V100 and the new P4, which
we just announced publicly
that's available on Google
Cloud for serving.
It's a view core that's
really specialized to serving.
So it doesn't have a
lot of onboard memory,
but it's really fast
and cheap, or cheaper
than some of the other
options for doing serving.
It's also, like I said,
present in the V100.
OK.
So back up to the
optimization process.
I talked about running
predictions and benchmarking
the baseline.
I think I actually
had a number up there
that was 189 seconds for
this particular MNIST CNN,
simple MNIST CNN, which
is, basically, I think,
1,000 executions of
a batch size of 100.
This is what it looks
like to freeze the graph.
As I said, we're calling
this freeze graph operation
using the Python API, which
is present in the Python tools
module under TensorFlow.
This freeze graph tool can
be called directly here.
It actually has
one of the largest
set of arguments
of any method call
that I've seen in TensorFlow.
I didn't put all of them here.
There's, like, 10 more
that are required.
They're not even optional.
But anyway, the sample code
shows you how to do this.
And then the output
is basically--
you're providing the
output graph file name,
and so it actually
writes the output graph
to the frozen output graph
for you when it completes.
This is what running
the optimizations
using the graph transform
tool looks like.
Again, you give it a list of the
tech transforms that you want
to run, then you run this
transform graph method,
and it produces the optimized
graph as the output.
Then you have to actually
go save that graph.
But again, the sample code
shows you how to do all that.
And then finally, you want to
convert back to saved model.
This turns out to be
unwieldy and harder
than you'd like it to be.
But basically, if you know
the right APIs to call,
it's not that bad.
You use the TF saved
model simple save method.
And again, you have to
provide the inputs--
a list of inputs and the list of
outputs that you want to save.
And so you have to
actually know that
or know what those nodes are.
In this example code,
we found the inputs
by just looking for a place
holder nodes, which essentially
are typically what would
provide the inputs to a graph.
We got the outputs, actually, by
looking at the meta graph def,
as I talked about.
The meta graph def
includes the signature
that gives a list
of the output nodes,
and so that's where
that came from.
And then the benchmark again,
after applying these set
of optimizations, and
instead of 189 seconds,
it takes 162 seconds.
So that's about a
15% improvement,
which is not bad for just
running a few optimizations.
And it's actually
significant enough
that it could make a
difference in cost and speed,
certainly, a difference
that you would care about.
Each of the optimizations
that we perform
should preserve the
output for a given input.
In other words,
hopefully-- again, this
is something we have to verify,
but there shouldn't be anything
that we did that would change
the output for a given input.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the quantization on it?
LUKMAN RAMSEY:
Actually, we didn't
do quantization this one.
Sorry--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yes.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: So TensorRT
actually only makes sense
if you're doing it on GPU.
In fact, really, by
definition, what it
is is preparing your
model so that it
is able to harness those
tensor cores that are
built into the V100 and the P4.
And I think all of the GPUs
going forward from NVIDIA,
or most of them, will
include this special unit.
TensorRT is a topic
in and of itself.
We can talk a little
bit about that.
There is sample code
out there that shows you
how to apply TensorRT.
Again, it's been present
inside the TensorFlow code base
since, I think, March
of last year, as of 1.7.
So it's reasonably stable.
But you also need to
use the NVIDIA Inference
Server in order to harness it.
Having said that,
if you really want
really high performing serving,
it's pretty much the way to go.
I also would say
you probably would
need to engage with NVIDIA
in order to make it work.
It's complicated
to get it to work.
We're just about to publish a--
actually, there's already been
a blog post that shows you
how to do this on V100s.
Just about to publish another
blog post that shows you
how to do it using the P4s.
So you'll have sample code
out there available if you're
interested in doing this.
But like I said, it's
something that you probably
need the help--
you'll probably end up needing
some technical help in order
to pull it off.
Over the course
of this year, I'm
sure the NVIDIA
Inference Server will get
more stable and more robust.
There are some other things to
say about the NVIDIA Inference
Server.
It's not dynamic, actually,
yet, like TF serving
is, which is a problem.
Almost every practical
ML application
is dynamic in some
sense, meaning,
you almost never train
a model on static data
and then just serve
it ad infinitum.
Typically, you're going
to update that model based
on new data at some point.
And so the process of
deploying the new model
gets much more complicated.
Because you have to have
your own system for doing
this hot-swap, or
you have to be able
bring the whole server down
and then swap in a new model
and bring it back up, or
something more complicated,
where you migrate traffic
over from-- you deploy
a new instance, and you
migrate-- so anyway, there's
a reason why TF
serving is dynamic,
is because it's actually a pain
when serving the infrastructure
is not dynamic.
AUDIENCE: So what did you do?
You said, you changed the
graph and you [INAUDIBLE]..
So how did you get
to [INAUDIBLE]??
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Those
other optimizations
that we performed did
make a difference.
So we still--
AUDIENCE: Which ones?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Let's go back.
This is the list that we talked
about that we were going to do.
So this removing identity
nodes, folding constants,
merging duplicate nodes,
actually, is a form of pruning.
You have two nodes
that are in succession
that do the same operation.
[INAUDIBLE] unused nodes,
meaning, any nodes that
are being calculated
but are not actually
connected to the output.
So that would include extra
output nodes, but also,
just like any-- there are
oftentimes nodes in your graph
that end up getting
added that are not--
there's no edge from that
node back to the output,
and so those nodes get pruned.
And then this
folding batch norms,
which we talked about as well.
So that's the set of
transforms that we did.
So this is a good topic.
This actually leads
me to the conclusion
of the talk, which is, the
truth is, that grappler, which
I mentioned, which is built
into the TensorFlow runtime,
is actually performing
all of those optimizations
that we listed.
And TF serving, which is the
serving mechanism that we used,
uses grappler.
But we still see the
results that we see.
We see them consistently
across multiple models.
We actually implemented this
using vanilla TensorFlow
and Keras, and all of that
sample code is in our repo.
And yet, we see this
performance increase.
I've been talking to the
folks both on the TF serving
side and the grappler
side to try to understand
why this is the case.
But it highlights
the fact that you
need to take control
of your serving.
If you care about
performance, you
should not rely necessarily on
everything working perfectly
under the hood.
You would like to,
but the reality
is is that, for some
reason, and I'm still
not sure why grappler is
not performing in the way
that it's supposed
to in this context,
but nonetheless, it's
very reproducible.
For some reason, the
grappler optimizations
that are supposed to be
happening inside of TensorFlow
serving are not happening.
So again, in an
ideal world, this set
of optimizations for most cases,
if you're using TF serving,
should not be necessary.
Now, there are some
cases where you're
doing another kind of serving
mechanism that you can't
rely on grappler kicking in.
And so this is a good,
useful knowledge to have.
But also, the reality is is
that despite grappler supposed
to be performing these
optimizations in the tests
that we ran, it was not.
And again, we'll
figure out why that is.
As you know, TensorFlow is a
very rapidly evolving system
and things don't
always work perfectly.
And so you should take control
over your own model process,
particularly if there
could be a 15% difference
in your performance.
And understanding all of these
processes and how to test
them is important.
But the reality is,
again, I think--
we discovered this after we
published the post in November,
that actually, grappler
is supposed to be applying
all these optimizations.
And because TF serving
users grappler,
these optimizations
shouldn't work, but they do.
And so something's wacky.
Again, maybe it's something
that we're doing, I don't know.
But we repeated these,
and like I said,
we did it on more
than just one model.
We did it using multiple APIs.
It was very consistent that we
saw about this 15% improvement.
So I don't have all
the answers here.
I don't know exactly
what's going on.
But anyway, this was, I
think, still a useful exercise
in understanding the
details of the model
formats and the optimization
processes and things
like quantization,
which we didn't do here,
but can be a really
important factor
in the efficiency of your
serving processes as well.
So that's the end here, again.
We had lots of questions--
really great questions
during the talk.
But if anybody else
has any more questions,
I'd be happy to take them now.
Yeah?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Like, would what
we're doing here change that?
Like, maybe--
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Right.
That's a good question.
So the whole topic
of explainability--
maybe I'll come back someday
and give a talk about that.
I've actually been
working on that myself.
A very, very hard,
but interesting topic
in the world of ML these days.
Lots of people are
interested in it.
The short answer is what
we did here should not
change the mathematical
result of the model, meaning,
none of the
optimizations that we
did here should change the
mathematical results that
are computed by the graph.
But again, you
have to test that.
Don't believe me.
That's why I said run the
predictions on a test set.
In the case of MNIST,
it's the MNIST data set.
And then run it
again and make sure
that your outputs look the
same for a given input.
This is not that hard to do.
There's only 60,000 examples
in the MNIST data set.
So you should really verify
that the numerical output
for a given input is the same.
But the truth is, all
the optimizations that
are performed here
should not have changed
the mathematical
calculations that are
being performed by the graph.
Interpretation is
another big topic
that we, unfortunately,
probably don't have time
to talk about much
today, but maybe I'll
come back and talk
about that later.
AUDIENCE: Just one
last [INAUDIBLE]
How do you create the benchmark
numbers on various [INAUDIBLE]??
For example, [INAUDIBLE]
35, 34, [INAUDIBLE]
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah,
the absolute values
of these benchmarks
will definitely
change according to the model.
And they will also,
the absolute values
will change depending on
which system you run on.
But the key thing we're looking
for is, are they consistent--
for a given model
on a given machine,
are they consistent
from run to run?
And the method that I
talked about here today
empirically is quite consistent.
AUDIENCE: And that was
for less than 34, right?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: No, no.
This is just a CNN
that we created
that's just a few layers,
very simple CNN to do MNIST.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah.
My pleasure.
No
problem.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Of layers?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Oh.
Yeah, that's a hard
question to answer.
Yeah, it really depends on
how the model's constructed
and what operations
are being used.
These big, deep CNNs that they
use to do image recognition,
again, like ResNet or Inception,
are actually quite complex
from an architectural
standpoint if you look down
in the details of how
they're constructed.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Which ones
are compressed the most,
or which ones--
yeah, I couldn't answer that.
I haven't actually done
a comparative survey.
Yeah?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: It should, yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
also a [INAUDIBLE]??
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Oh, no.
There's nothing that
we could do here
that would make your
model more accurate.
There are definitely
things we could
do that would make it less.
AUDIENCE: Yes, actually.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yes.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: For
a given accuracy--
again, if you're
processing medical imagery,
you probably do care about the
throughput and the predictions
speed.
Because those are
very big images
and the models that you're using
probably are quite big as well.
And so it can make
a big difference
in the amount of time that
it takes or the costs.
So these optimizations
make sense, although,
again, theoretically,
you shouldn't have
to perform them in many cases.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah.
We're actually not here
concerned with optimizing
accuracy.
That's the realm of training.
The whole world of making your
models as accurate as possible
is this world of training,
which people talk about a lot.
They talk about how
to optimize training
and how to distribute
training and how
to make training go fast.
You don't see as
many people talking
about how to optimize serving.
That was one of the
motivations that we had for
doing this work.
Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yes.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: There
are coding changes.
But hopefully, not too invasive.
Yeah, not too extensive.
If you're using
the estimator APR,
then it's actually
pretty minimal.
And I don't know about Keras
yet with respect to TPUs.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: OK.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: That's right.
Actually, I couldn't
ever believe
how we would expose to the
outside world a TPU for free.
I know.
Somehow we managed to do that.
But yeah.
You would figure some
bitcoin miners would've
figured out how to
take advantage of that
somehow by now.
Yeah?
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Yeah.
So if you go look on the
documentation for this graph
transform tool,
there are actually
lots of parameters and
ways that you can adjust
or optional transforms
that you can perform
that may be more aggressive.
We don't have the time to
talk about all that here.
But yeah, there are
some more experimental
transforms as well that can be
performed that have a greater
likelihood of
changing your results
or potentially not
working with your graph.
So yeah, this
world of transforms
is actually quite deep and
rich when you dig into it.
And again, most of the
time, in most contexts,
you wouldn't have to
know all this stuff
because the TensorFlow
runtime is doing it for you.
But as we saw here,
it's useful to know
because maybe
something went wrong
and the TensorFlow runtime
isn't working correctly
or a TF serving is
not working correctly,
or that you may not
be using TF serving.
There are applications that were
in IoT where people are running
predictions on an edge device,
or even a Raspberry Pi,
where you're not going
to be able to get
TF serving on that device.
And so it's good to know how
to do this kind of stuff.
Also, just to understand
better, for example,
what frameworks like TF
Lite, TensorFlow Lite
are doing under the hood
to optimize your graphs.
So yeah, it's a very
interesting, deep world,
most of which is
happening under the hood
and you know you
don't hear about it.
But we're hoping to expose
some of this information
to the public as
part of this work.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]